y muchas de las formas en que
representamos funciones de varias
variables suponen que comprendemos muy
bien la forma de representar puntos y
vectores en tres dimensiones así que
esto es lo que veremos en el siguiente
vídeo verdad y quizás sea un buen punto
de partida hablar de este tipo de
detalles de puntos y vectores en dos
dimensiones verdad porque cuando digamos
hay una buena analogía de hecho cuando
uno comienza a comparar dos dimensiones
y tres dimensiones
vemos patrones que se pueden después
extender a otras dimensiones que de
hecho no podemos visualizar verdad o
podríamos determinar cosas que nos
convienen en una en una dimensión que
quizás en otra dimensión no no son
válidos muy bien entonces aquí
nuestros dos ejes y pongamos un punto un
punto cualquiera en este espacio
de aquí ok y recordemos que este punto
se encuentra en dos dimensiones aquí
tenemos nuestro eje x nuestro eje y
verdad y además estos dos ejes son
perpendiculares entre sí muy bien
entonces ahí lo tenemos y digamos que la
coordenada de este punto o las las
coordenadas de este punto es son 13 bien
aquí tenemos las coordenadas de este
punto muy bien qué significa esto bueno
lo que significa es que nos tenemos que
mover en la dirección x una digamos una
unidad
pero en la dirección que nos va nos
movemos 3 y quizás este dibujo en en
realidad no está en una escala apropiada
pero estamos sentando estamos sentando
ideas verdad entonces aquí tenemos cómo
es que podemos representar este punto y
todo punto se puede representar así
verdad son son como las instrucciones
que te dicen digamos que tanto seguir en
una dirección y que tanto seguir en la
otra dirección y también podríamos
pensar al revés verdad si tenemos dos
números o dos cosas podemos pensar los
en dos dimensiones verdad así que en
tres dimensiones tenemos la misma
relación entre tercios de números y
puntos en el espacio así que digamos
pongamos un punto en el espacio y ahí
digamos al inicio es difícil ver dónde
se halla verdad hasta que movemos estas
cosas para poder darle perspectiva así
que nosotros describimos los puntos de
esta forma nuevamente con un conjunto de
coordenadas pero en esta ocasión es una
tercia verdad y en este punto particular
resulta ser que las coordenadas son
125 y esos números lo que nos están
diciendo es que tanto nos movemos de
forma paralela a cada uno de los ejes
así que justo como en dos dimensiones
tenemos un eje x un eje y pero ahora
tenemos un tercer eje que es
perpendicular a ambos verdad y digamos
eso es lo que nos hace movernos en la
tercera dimensión este es el eje z y en
el primer número en nuestras coordenadas
verdad lo que nos está diciendo es que
tanto nos movemos en la dirección x como
digamos nuestro primer paso en el
segundo número es digamos el caso 2 lo
que nos está diciendo es que tanto nos
movemos en la dirección paralela al eje
y que ese es el segundo paso y el tercer
número nos dice que tanto nos movemos
digamos hacia arriba para alcanzar ese
punto verdad y esto lo podemos hacer en
realidad para cualquier punto del
espacio de tres dimensiones verdad así
que cualquier punto que tenemos digamos
podemos dar las instrucciones de cómo
movernos a lo largo del eje x paralelo
al eje i
cómo movernos de forma paralela al eje z
para llegar a ese punto lo que significa
verdad que otra vez tenemos esta
dicotomía entre las tercias de números y
los puntos en tres dimensiones así que
siempre que tengas una tercia de cosas y
de hecho vamos a ver un poquito más de
esto en el próximo vídeo pero siempre
que estemos hablando por ejemplo de
gráficas en tres dimensiones
verás que solo por el hecho de ser una
tercia de números o de cosas dirás claro
debería estar pensando de alguna forma
en tres dimensiones verdad de la misma
forma que siempre que tenemos parejas de
cosas deberíamos estar pensando en una
cosa que es de dos dimensiones bueno
finalmente tenemos otra forma de ver a
los pares de números y son los vectores
y los vectores esencialmente son flechas
que van desde el origen de nuestro plano
coordenada hasta el punto que estamos
representando verdad así que esta flecha
de aquí
un vector y típicamente lo representamos
con una flecha verdad sus coordenadas
serán las digamos las mismas coordenadas
que las coordenadas de este punto solo
que los vamos a poner digamos por
convención en una columna así que las
coordenadas de ese vector sera
la forma
una columna así que en realidad digo no
está escrito en piedra verdad pero
nuestra convención será que si vemos una
pareja entre paréntesis verdad en
horizontal entonces estamos pensando en
un punto si lo vemos digamos de forma
vertical y entre corchetes es un vector
y aunque ambas son formas válidas de
representar vectores o puntos la
diferencia principal es que para el
vector
digamos pudimos haber iniciado en
cualquier otro punto digamos no se
pudimos haber iniciado por aquí
y trazar el mismo digamos la misma
flecha solo que iniciando en este otro
punto de lo único es que si tendríamos
que movernos una dirección digamos en la
dirección horizontal una unidad hacia la
derecha y tres hacia arriba verdad esa
es la única cuestión que tenemos que
considerar cuando trazamos vectores y
típicamente estos representan digamos
movimiento de algún tipo muy bien la
otra cosa interesante de los vectores es
que podemos sumar los podemos sumar
vectores entonces digamos que tenemos
otra flecha digamos que tiene una
componente x grande pero tiene una
componente y negativa
otra flecha verdad y la suma de estos
dos vectores o de estas dos flechas era
digamos vamos a poner esta misma flecha
justo iniciando dónde termina la otra
flecha entonces más o menos
algo así verdad y la suma de estos dos
vectores será justo la flecha o el
vector que empieza en el origen y
termina donde digamos en el punto
terminal de esta segunda flecha verdad
y entonces esta sería esencialmente la
suma de nuestros dos vectores y lo mismo
podemos hacer en tres dimensiones verdad
dado un punto podemos dibujar una flecha
que vaya del origen hacia ese punto
verdad y esta flecha estaría
representada con la misma tercia de
números pero típicamente lo ponemos
digamos en una columna verdad ya este le
llamamos un vector columna verdad y la
diferencia entre el punto y la flecha es
que en realidad podríamos pensar que la
flecha de nuestro vector empieza en
cualquier lugar del espacio verdad en
realidad no importa siempre y cuando
tenga digamos las mismas componentes
verdad así que en realidad lo que
importa es que tanto nos movemos en
dirección paralela del eje x que tanto
nos movemos en dirección paralela al eje
y y que tanto en dirección paralela al
eje z así que en el próximo vídeo te
mostraré cómo usar estas digamos ideas
en tres dimensiones para empezar a
graficar funciones multi variables